J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour, il fait beau en Belgique, ça n'arrive pas si souvent. J'espère que vous en profitez bien.
D'ailleurs, peut-être que vous m'écoutez déjà sur la route des vacances. On termine cette saison avec un épisode tout aussi solaire puisque je suis rejoint par Olivier Bailly, qui est journaliste depuis vingt ans
et cofondateur de Médor en 2012, 2014, 2015.
C'est pas très clair, mais si vous ne connaissez pas Médor, c'est une revue trimestrielle belge qui se consacre aux sujets de société.
Donc là, normalement, vu le public, vous devriez déjà avoir quelques atomes crochus, et qui met en lumière des problématiques grâce à un journalisme d'investigation de toute première qualité et une narration délicieuse.
Avec Olivier, on est revenu sur le pourquoi du comment de Médor, mais on a aussi parlé des enjeux médiatiques et journalistiques en Belgique, et même un peu de scoutisme, vous allez voir.
Je vous souhaite une très bonne écoute. Et j'ai le plaisir d'être aujourd'hui avec Olivier Bailly. Salut Olivier.
Salut.
Olivier, on va parler aujourd'hui ensemble de journalisme pour clôturer cette saison. Tu es journaliste indépendant depuis vingt ans, cofondateur évidemment de Médor, déjà depuis dix ans.
Tu coordonnes à l'IHECS un master en horaires décalés, tu nous reparleras de ça peut-être un peu plus tard.
Tu as deux prix Belfius à ton actif, deux documentaires sur le surendettement et sur Ikea, et tu es l'auteur de quatre romans.
Je sais pas comment tu as le temps de faire toutes ces choses en même temps, mais quatre romans, donc, tu écris depuis combien de temps déjà ?
Depuis vingt ans aussi, à peu près.
Mais environ, ouais, je suis sorti de l'IHECS, donc l'école de journalisme, en nonante-sept, et donc depuis, j'écris.
Voilà. Et donc, tu écris autant, ouais, en journaliste indépendant directement, tu n'as jamais travaillé dans une rédaction à proprement parler.
Alors, j'ai été engagé à un moment donné au CNCD Operation 1111, donc la plateforme des organisations de solidarité internationale.
Et là, j'avais un mi-temps qui était un mi-temps de journaliste pour un magazine qui n'existe plus, qui s'appelle Demain Le Monde, qui a par ailleurs fusionné avec Imagine.
Et voilà, c'était ma seule expérience en tant que salarié. Le reste du temps, c'était en chômeur ou indépendant.
Ouais, j'ai aussi toujours été, ou
presque toujours été indépendant. Qu'est-ce que ça dit de toi, en fait, le fait que tu n'aies jamais voulu vraiment intégrer la rédaction de, je sais pas, RTL, Le Soir, La Libre, etc. ?
Alors, c'est gentil de croire qu'ils m'ont fait une offre.
Ah oui, c'est ça. Qu'est-ce que ça dit du secteur et de la précarité ? Le fait que tu n'aies jamais eu d'offre là-bas.
Je pense qu'il y a deux paramètres. Il y a la société et moi. Je pense que,
peut-être que je ne correspondais pas à ce que les rédactions recherchaient, au moment où j'aurais pu être engagé dans l'une de ces rédactions.
Et je crois aussi que quand je me suis retrouvé sur le marché du journalisme en 2003,
on était en plein virage Web, Internet, et je pense qu'il y avait aussi une frénésie à ce moment-là, comme on peut l'avoir par rapport à l'intelligence artificielle maintenant,
par rapport à un nouveau média qu'il fallait maîtriser, qui demandait de l'urgence, qui demandait de la réactivité, qui demandait
d'être extrêmement rapide sur la balle, et ce qui est pas du tout à la fois le journalisme que moi, je voulais faire,
et ni même mes compétences.
Je crois que ça a joué aussi dans le fait qu'à un moment donné, je n'avais pas forcément ma place dans ce type de journalisme.
Dès le départ, tu avais une préférence marquée pour alors le journalisme d'investigation, le fond, le travail sur la durée ?
Alors, oui, j'ai toujours eu une appétence pour le journalisme, en effet, long. Pas forcément que l'investigation, ça peut être du récit, mais je me suis—
alors, j'ai travaillé à un moment donné tout de même pour les pages bruxelloises du Soir, donc j'ai quand même fait du journalisme quotidien, mais c'est
Toujours en indépendant alors.
Et toujours en tant qu'indépendant, mais c'est sûr que j'ai toujours privilégié le fait de pouvoir développer plutôt des projets journalistiques qu'une carrière ou des articles.
Mh, mh. Et d'où est-ce que ça te vient, alors, ce profil-là, de préférer nettement, nettement le travail sur le long terme, la profondeur plutôt que...
Bah, je pense qu'on fait des choix à un moment donné, qu'on est porté par des envies de contribuer à la société et que moi, ma manière de trouver une place, j'ai pas de fascination pour le journalisme, par exemple.
Quand j'étais petit, je voulais pas être absolument journaliste coûte que coûte. Donc c'était très clair quand j'ai terminé pour moi mes études à l'IHECS, dans lequel on fait un mémoire pratique, un mémoire théorique.
Donc ce sont des choses qui nous inscrivent dans le long, où à un moment donné, on développe des projets pendant un an ou six mois.
Et là, c'était assez évident pour moi que c'était ce que je voulais faire, et qu'en aucun cas un autre type de journalisme. Qui peut être un journalisme.
Alors j'ai pas de problème avec le journalisme réactif et rapide parce que c'est un journalisme que je consomme beaucoup aussi et qui est une forme de journalisme de veille pour lequel j'ai beaucoup de respect,
mais par contre qui peut à un moment donné dans de mauvaises conditions de travail produire un journalisme médiocre parce qu'on ne respecte pas la déontologie et les méthodologies journalistiques.
Et il était clair pour moi que je voulais pas faire ce type de—
je voulais pas gâcher en fait le métier. Donc je voulais faire quelque chose de bien et encore maintenant en fait,
je crois que ce qui m'importe, c'est plus le processus, la manière de travailler qui s'approche de l'artisanat, même si après on peut en discuter du mot, que véritablement de faire du journalisme.
Et donc tu expliquais que, voilà, le journalisme,
ne te passionnait pas quand tu étais plus jeune. Et finalement, si je comprends bien, tu voulais surtout un impact sociétal et tu aurais pu le faire peut-être autrement.
Mais je suis pas sûr que je suis un être à ce point réflexif qui fait qu'à mes dix-huit ou à mes vingt ans, je me dis : « Tiens, je prends telle position dans la société ».
Je crois que je voulais surtout, j'ai toujours eu une forme de, à la fois besoin d'exprimer des choses par rapport à la société tout en me tenant en retrait.
Et c'est un peu la position de nouveau de l'artisan.
De l'observateur surtout.
De l'observateur, c'est-à-dire apporter quelque chose, assumer tout de même son regard, assumer cette envie de contribuer à la société, de la raconter,
tout en disant que ma personne est quelque chose qui doit se situer en retrait parce que c'est plutôt les faits observés qui ont une valeur.
Et ça, c'est vrai que je l'ai toujours, je pense que je l'ai toujours porté, même inconsciemment, cette envie de pouvoir raconter un peu ce que, raconter la société.
Raconter. Oui, oui. D'où donc l'aspect, le côté narratif, finalement, qu'on retrouve très fort dans Médor.
Donc, tu n'aurais peut-être pas pu devenir sociologue alors. Tu n'aurais peut-être pas pu écrire des mémoires avec un côté narratif, ça aurait été compliqué.
Ça n'a jamais été une perspective.
Super. Médor, si on explique un petit peu aux gens de quoi il s'agit pour celles et ceux qui ne connaissent pas encore, le pitch, tu le fais comment ?
Le pitch, Médor, c'est un magazine trimestriel qui vous offre de l'information belge,
information qui est, moi, c'est ce que j'appelle du journalisme pièce à conviction, c'est-à-dire qu'on travaille sur les faits,
on ne fait pas d'humeur, on fait pas d'analyse, on fait pas de commentaires, on fait pas de carte blanche, on fait pas d'opinion.
Vous faites pas d'interview non plus.
On fait une interview.
OK. OK, c'est long.
On fait une interview, mais la seule page plus subjective, je vais dire, où on va amener une forme de, justement, de commentaire, c'est l'édito.
Le reste, en fait, ce sont des investigations, des récits, des reportages longs. Il y a une interview, il y a une BD.
Et donc c'est une manière de justement alimenter notre territoire, notre territoire belge en le regardant, en y allant, en mettant nos bottes pour aller dans la boue et en racontant la Belgique que l'on rencontre.
Et c'est donc en trimestriel. Ça, c'est sur le contenu, mais alors le contenant, je trouve est intéressant aussi.
Et sur le contenu, surtout, vous vous concentrez sur les sujets de société.
Sur les sujets de société, oui.
Un petit peu comme—
Voilà.
Certains podcasts.
Voilà. On n'a pas une ligne éditoriale où on va dire, on va traiter spécifiquement d'une matière, on va mettre vraiment l'accent sur l'environnement, le politique, l'économique, le sport.
On prend tout ce qui va avoir lien avec la société belge. Mais pour expliquer Médor, ce qui est important aussi, c'est que donc ça, c'est le contenu, mais le contenant est aussi important.
Donc on s'est créé en coopérative. C'est un média qui a essayé de—  c'est pas juste créé, c'est-à-dire que c'est un média qui a cherché aussi à s'inventer.
Et donc on a cherché de nouvelles méthodes pour créer l'information. Avec l'élément le plus évident, c'est la rédaction tournante.
Donc y a pas de rédacteur ou rédactrice en chef dans Médor. Ce sont des
duos qui tournent numéro après numéro et qui apportent du coup un nouveau regard, une nouvelle manière de, à un moment donné, traiter la ligne éditoriale de chacun des numéros.
Mh. Et ces duos, ces rédacteurs, vous les trouvez comment ? En fait, c'est eux qui viennent vers vous ?
Non. Alors, on est cinq fondateurs et fondatrices pour l'instant à faire ce travail de pilote, que l'on appelle.
Oui, c'est ça, oui.
Et donc, ce sont les cinq mêmes personnes—
D'accord.
Qui se relaient au fur et à mesure.
OK.
Moi, par exemple, je sors, alors c'est un peu particulier, mais je sors des trois derniers numéros et je ne rentre plus dans le pilotage avant octobre deux mille vingt-cinq. Donc la ligne—
Voilà, dans douze mois. Enfin, quatorze.
Tu prends un petit peu de repos alors ?
Alors, je prends pas de repos, enfin peut-être un peu quand même.
J'espère.
On va essayer. Mais c'est ce qui est intéressant avec Médor, c'est que,
et ce qui peut être aussi discuté parce que ça donne aussi une forme de précarité à notre journalisme, c'est qu'on est tous les cinq indépendants et donc, quand on rentre dans Médor, on a la rémunération qui va avec.
Et quand on en sort, on développe d'autres projets. Ce qui donne, à mon avis, comme force à Médor, qu'à un moment donné, on développe aussi d'autres univers journalistiques.
Moi, là, j'ai en projet un documentaire et deux livres. Ça me permet, moi, de m'inscrire dans autre chose et puis de revenir aussi avec des idées, des envies pour le magazine.
Et je trouve que ça nous fait aussi beaucoup de bien, et les autres fonctionnent de la même manière.
Est-ce que tu veux nous teaser ces documentaires et ces livres ou bien c'est encore trop tôt ?
Non, je peux en parler, y a rien de secret. Je pense que le documentaire, donc c'est un travail qui est mené avec la boîte de production Wrong Men.
Et qui sera en coproduction avec la RTBF qui a—  c'est un documentaire sur les paris sportifs. Donc c'est un article que j'avais
OK
écrit il y a de ça un an ou deux. Et puis la boîte de production est venue nous trouver en disant : « J'aimerais développer une collection Médor.
» Ce qui nous semblait intéressant. On en a discuté, on leur a teasé quelques sujets, ils ont pris les paris sportifs.
Et donc l'idée, c'est de commencer peut-être une collection, on va voir comment ça va se passer avec ce premier numéro qui, si tout se passe bien, devrait sortir en 2025.
Mh.
Et puis les deux autres projets de livres. Le premier, c'est un livre de—
une forme de biographie de François Collinet, qui à la fois est un ami, un journaliste, un sociologue, un sexologue et qui a aussi comme identité d'avoir vécu toute sa vie en chaise roulante—
Mh
puisque dès sa naissance, donc il a eu un handicap cérébral moteur. Et ce qui est intéressant chez François, c'est qu'il doit réinventer tout ce qui peut sembler être la norme.
Or, dans le genre normé, y a pas plus normé que moi, genre homme blanc, 50 ans, hétérosexuel, voilà, bobo moyen. Enfin bref, j'arrête de me flatter.
Mais malgré tout, voilà, je suis très normé, François ne l'est pas du tout. Ce qui est intéressant, c'est qu'on doit discuter de choses à un moment donné que je n'ai pas forcément réfléchies.
Et François passe par la même chose que tout le monde passe.
Mh.
Mais il a un temps d'avance parce qu'il a dû réfléchir l'amour, l'amitié, la vie professionnelle, la mobilité.
La sexualité, ouais.
Et la sexualité. Et voilà. Du coup, lui prend la parole dans le livre et moi, je retrace sa vie.
Mh.
Donc c'est un livre à—
Un livre sous forme d'interview ou vraiment c'est une biographie ?
Non, non, non. J'ai fait une série—  ça fait deux ou trois ans que je fais des entretiens avec François. Et puis à un moment donné, je
prends des moments que moi, j'identifie comme charnières et je les raconte, et entre ces moments, François va également les raconter.
Maintenant, honnêtement, le livre est en construction, donc si ça tombe, la structure va encore évoluer.
Mh.
Et le dernier projet qui me tient beaucoup à cœur, c'est un focus sur la santé mentale en Belgique, avec un cas particulier qui me concerne.
Du coup, j'ai un ami qui s'est suicidé il y a de ça deux ans et je l'avais pas mal accompagné les dernières années dans ses démarches, dans des discussions, dans la manière de pouvoir ou non le soigner.
Et voilà, j'ai du coup été observateur en première ligne de failles, de réussites et de manquements de la société.
Et sans vouloir chercher un coupable, mais surtout vouloir chercher à comprendre comment on en est arrivé là, je raconte son histoire en fait.
OK, OK. Donc là, il y a vraiment—  tu es impliqué directement dans l'histoire ou tu... ?
Alors, je suis impliqué en tant que, de nouveau observateur, parce que j'étais vraiment en première ligne de tout ce qui s'est
T'expliques que tu l'as un peu—  t'étais là à ses côtés.
Donc je vais tout de même utiliser ma présence, mais de manière—  enfin, je ne suis pas du tout le sujet, évidemment.
Non.
Mais par contre, comme c'est mon ami, je me positionne tout de même comme étant la personne qui était à côté de la personne que je raconte, ouais.
Mh. Je remarque que tu travailles—  donc les exemples que tu as donnés, c'est donc sous forme de livres. Tu t'es jamais intéressé à d'autres formats, par exemple des reportages, des documentaires en vidéo ?
Alors, j'ai tendance à vouloir... J'aime beaucoup écrire.
Mh.
J'aime par ailleurs beaucoup lire également. Je crois que c'est vraiment mon média de cœur.
OK.
Et j'ai pas cette appétence de vouloir faire de la radio, de la télé, du web, de la data, de... Alors c'est peut-être un manque de curiosité, mais
Mais tu en écoutes ?
J'en écoute et j'en regarde, mais je suis avant tout en effet pour l'écrit et le récit long et je m'y sens bien en fait.
OK.
Et je m'y sens tellement bien que je vois pas vraiment, nos vies sont courtes. Chaque projet, c'est six mois, un an, un an et demi.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai pas cette envie d'aller voir ces nouveaux territoires.
Mh. Et oui, la question de l'accessibilité du reportage, la question de toucher un public plus large, etc.
J'ai l'impression hein, que dans, au cœur de Médor, il y a pas tellement ces enjeux-là, il y a pas tellement ces questions de : et si on élargissait notre public ?
Et si on touchait un public plus large et plus facile, entre guillemets ?
Alors la question est là. On vit quand même pas dans une tour d'ivoire, mais,
on voit bien le danger, en fait, de ce type de réflexion qui a été dans le monde journalistique, c'est, à un moment donné, d'adapter totalement le contenu ou grandement le contenu
afin de répondre à une éventuelle demande de ce fameux opinion publique ou de monsieur et madame Tout-le-monde.
Tu ne vas pas lancer le format Médor sur TikTok ? C'est pas prévu ?
Bah, c'est pas prévu. Après, je m'occupe pas des réseaux sociaux, mais ça pourrait l'être si on réinvente la présence. Moi, je crois que c'est pas tellement le support, le problème.
Mh.
C'est, est-ce qu'on fait un journalisme de l'offre ? Et qu'est-ce que l'on a à offrir à TikTok pour le public de TikTok à ce moment-là ?
Si on a quelque chose d'intelligent, qui réinvente le genre, pourquoi pas ? Mais par contre, ça doit être réfléchi.
Ça n'a aucune-- commencer à diffuser pour diffuser dans un seul but, à un moment donné, d'augmenter notre notoriété, ce qui par ailleurs est toujours un échec quand on fait une démarche aussi simplificatrice.
Euh, ça, ça n'a pas deee,
ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens, en fait. Je crois que l'idée, c'est de faire d'un journalisme de l'offre, de faire quelque chose qui nous intéresse, d'avoir le pari que des personnes vont s'y intéresser, et c'est le cas,
et tout de même de rendre la chose accessible.
Mais on va pas faire des articles de mille signes parce qu'on part du présupposé que les personnes ne lisent plus.
Mh, mh. Donc en dix minutes, on a déjà vraiment une bonne idée de ton profil, hein. Le sujet de fond,
pas tellement intéressé par élargir le public, plutôt un grand amateur de l'écrit, autant pour la lecture que pour l'écriture.
Un focus sur la Belgique, tu l'as dit-
Ouais.
...sur les sujets de société. Là, pour le coup, je m'y retrouve pas mal puisque effectivement-- donc vous faites jamais des sujets sur, par exemple, les États-Unis, la France, autre chose ?
Alors, je fais un petit correctif dans ton résumé. C'est pas intéressé par élargir le public, si, évidemment. Si demain tu me dis plutôt que de vendre six mille, six mille cinq cents exemplaires, vous en vendez soixante-cinq-
Quand je dis élargir le public, c'était élargir les profils, les profils ciblés à monsieur et madame Tout-le-monde, comme tu disais.
On ne va pas modi-- donc mon point d'at-- 'fin, et notre point d'attention, c'est ce que l'on offre, c'est le contenu. Donc on essaye de faire quelque chose qui est agréable, pédagogique, accessible,
mais ça n'est pas-- l'objectif principal n'est pas d'atteindre cent mille personnes.
Mh.
L'objectif est de faire du journalisme qui contribue à la société. Et ensuite, si ça rencontre cent mille personnes, je serai le premier ravi. Mais-
Et spécifiquement la société belge francophone.
Et la société belge francophone, puisque-
C'est votre public, c'est votre sujet, c'est votre support, c'est une coopérative belge locale.
Voilà. Pour deux choses, c'était une forme de force de pénétration, c'est-à-dire si on travaille sur une surface qui est plus petite, on va être plus pertinent, et c'est la société dans laquelle on vit, donc ça a du sens qu'on en parle.
Et l'autre chose, c'est que de manière beaucoup plus pragmatique, si on devait attaquer le marché francophone, c'est évident qu'on va s'y épuiser et qu'on va y mourir.
Comme il se trouve que le Parlement européen est à Bruxelles, ça fait qu'on peut toucher à ces enjeux-là aussi.
Alors, on y touche, on n'y touche pas beaucoup. On y a touché dans le dernier numéro où on a fait-
Oui, ça, y a une cover derrière toi qui te fait mentir là.
Oui, oui. Donc, on y touche un peu. On a fait en effet un sujet sur le harcèlement au sein des institutions européennes.
Toujours sur-- avec l'axe des sujets de société, pas tellement les trilogues, le Conseil européen, les négociations, la présidence belge, etc.
C'est pas le focus.
Non, c'est pas notre focus.
Très bien. Donc on est rapidement passés dessus, mais donc tu parlais du format. Tu faisais référence au fait que c'est une coopérative.
Cette idée-là vient du fait de préserver votre indépendance et éviter l'influence de tiers, de publicitaires, de riches Bolloré qui pourraient racheter le média ou des choses comme ça.
C'est vraiment une idée de : on veut rester indépendant, on veut rester flexible.
Mais alors oui, on veut rester indépendant. Tu trouveras pas un média qui se dit pas indépendant.
Donc une fois qu'on a sorti le mantra, il va falloir à un moment donné l'expliquer ou en tout cas le défendre et l'argumenter sur la manière dont on organise notre indépendance, parce qu'on a des dépendances par ailleurs aussi.
Je voudrais peut-être revenir alors à la naissance de Médor, parce que Médor, c'est vraiment une initiative de ce qu'on appelait des porteurs de sens.
Alors, c'est peut-être un peu présomptueux, mais il y avait des journalistes, mais il y avait un auteur BD, un auteur photo, et il y avait aussi des développeurs, des graphistes qui ont à un moment donné discuté le projet et la coopérative.
Mais l'idée s'est assez vite posée de : on n'a pas de fric. Et comme on n'a pas d'argent pour lancer le magazine, qu'il fallait tout de même une somme, on estimait ça à quatre-vingt, cent mille euros au moins pour le lancement.
Une des pistes qui a été évoquée, c'était la coopérative.
Et la coopérative nous donnait non seulement de l'argent, mais une obligation de transparence et une forme de gouvernance qui avait beaucoup de valeur dans un milieu journalistique, puisqu'on rendait des comptes et on partageait le pouvoir.
Et ça a été, je pense, une des meilleures idées qui a émergé dans le projet Médor, c'est de, à un moment donné, redonner cet espace collectif dans le milieu journalistique.
Et ça nous a permis aussi de récolter suffisamment d'argent pour lancer Médor et avoir l'assurance qu'on pouvait tenir deux numéros.
Donc une structure qui fonctionne avec, entre guillemets, deux chambres, avec les coopérateurs et les fondateurs pour maintenir une forme de, voilà, garder la main sur le volant, entre guillemets.
Est-ce qu'il est déjà arrivé qu'il y ait un désaccord important entre les coopérateurs d'un côté et les fondateurs de l'autre ?
Je pense qu'il y a jamais eu de désaccord entre coopérateurs-
Donc vous êtes très organisés.
...entre la chambre des coopérateurs et coopératrices et des fondateurs, fondatrices. Simplement parce que je crois que c'est une des faiblesses des coopératives,
ou une des difficultés, c'est qu'on a eu-- la part est pas très chère chez nous, elle est à vingt euros, donc on a beaucoup d'engagement, de soutien parce que les gens pensent que c'est important qu'un projet de société comme Médor existe.
Mais ensuite, y a pas forcément un désintérêt, mais le soutien a été marqué et la personne ne vient pas aux AG.
Personne ne vient aux assemblées, finalement.
Mais donc, y a pas grand monde qui vient aux assemblées. C'est peut-être sur la dimension participative. On a 1 900 coopérateurs et coopératrices.
C'est un défi, en fait, de pouvoir les mobiliser, d'utiliser toutes leurs compétences ou ce qu'ils pourraient nous apporter.
Mmh.
Et honnêtement, aujourd'hui, Médor n'est pas équipé pour pouvoir animer cette communauté.
Et donc ça explique que c'est une communauté qui nous fait confiance et qui, à un moment donné, suit les lignes directrices qui sont impulsées à l'AG.
Quand tu dis « pas équipé », c'est vraiment juste une limite technique ou c'est, vous n'avez pas un amphithéâtre à disposition pour accueillir,
1 900 personnes, ou bien c'est même juste, numériquement, les outils, Internet, etc., vous n'avez pas mis ça en place ?
Non, je crois que c'est pas une question tant d'outils numériques-
Mmh-mmh.
...que d'outils pédagogiques, d'animation, de participation. Si c'est pour faire pousser sur un bouton 1 900 personnes, ça, on peut le faire.
Ouais, d'accord, OK.
Par contre, comment est-ce qu'on peut renforcer la connaissance de 1 900 personnes sur Médor, sur les enjeux qui sont liés au journalisme aujourd'hui en Belgique ?
Ça, c'est un énorme challenge. C'est comme le G1000 de,
de David Van Reybrouck. C'est qu'à un moment donné,
si on veut que les gens se positionnent sur la mobilité, à Bruxelles, par exemple, on n'a pas besoin d'avoir des experts de mobilité, mais on a besoin de renforcer la connaissance et les compétences en mobilité des personnes qui vont
se prononcer et qui ensuite viennent avec leur expérience, leur vécu.
Pour le Médor, c'est la même chose. On n'a pas besoin d'avoir 1 900 experts en journalisme, en communication, en marketing, surtout pas.
Par contre, si aujourd'hui, on demandait aux 1 900 personnes de se prononcer sur l'avenir de Médor, c'est tout de même important de connaître le contexte
journalistique, que l'on puisse expliquer le virage dans lequel on est, la disparition des librairies, le fait que des titres, d'ici cinq ans, vont switcher complètement sur le numérique.
Donc, on va perdre l'aspect physique qui est un aspect très important pour Médor. Comment est-ce qu'on se réinvente, en fait, dans ce paysage qui, dans cinq ans, sera complètement différent ?
Ce que tu dis là, c'est un scénario fictif ou bien c'est acté, le physique va disparaître ?
Non.
Pour Médor.
Pour Médor, certainement pas. Mais dans le paysage aujourd'hui journalistique et notamment dans la presse papier, on voit bien que les locomotives qui font qu'il existe encore des librairies sont en train de, euh-
Perdre de vitesse.
...d'une perte de vitesse ou d'une vitesse qui reste la même, mais qui est en train de switcher avec un public qui utilise de plus en plus son smartphone et consulte de plus en plus les quotidiens ou les hebdomadaires sur son téléphone.
À partir de là, comment est-ce que les librairies vont tenir ? Si les librairies, c'est--
si les librairies ne tiennent plus, comment Médor va retrouver des points de vente et comment Médor va réussir à continuer à être physique, ce qui est quand même une dimension importante pour un trimestriel.
Mmh. Donc, ouais, OK, il faut qu'un minimum les coopérateurs aient les infos avant de pouvoir commenter, avant de pouvoir contribuer sur les décisions à prendre.
Les informations, il faut qu'on puisse échanger dessus.
Ouais.
C'est pas juste une forme de transmission de documents. Il faut qu'on soit sûr de-- qu'on puisse à un moment donné nourrir la réflexion, que les gens puissent poser leurs questions, qu'ils puissent assimiler la matière...
Et vous avez des projets là-dessus, à court terme, long terme, pour améliorer ça, ou bien c'est pas-- vous avez pas le temps, vous avez pas l'énergie ?
Honnêtement, je pense que c'est un autre métier.
D'accord.
Je crois que ce serait extrêmement précieux pour Médor, mais compte tenu de la situation et de nos limites, je crois qu'aujourd'hui, on ne peut pas développer la coopérative ou en tout cas animer la coopérative.
Et ce serait, je crois, au détriment du coup du cœur de métier de Médor qui est le journalisme.
Mmh. Donc ma question au départ de savoir si y avait des conflits au niveau des décisions entre les coopérateurs et les fondateurs, ta réponse, finalement, c'est de dire : la coopérative, surtout là, en tant que structure,
presque structure économique quoi, c'est le soutien et pas tellement l'éditorial.
Alors, c'est certainement pas l'éditorial puisque l'éditorial, c'est véritablement en rédaction que cela se passe. Donc la coopérative est le véhicule qui permet à la revue Médor d'exister, au magazine Médor d'exister.
Donc y a pas d'intervention éditoriale dans la coopérative. Par contre, il peut y avoir des interventions sur le projet en tant que tel, mais le projet dans sa diffusion, de pouvoir dire à un moment donné
: « On voudrait switcher Médor complètement en numérique. »
Mmh-mmh, ou en mensuel ou-
Ou en mensuel. Sans doute que l'AG pourrait se prononcer sur ces dimensions. Mais elle se prononce aussi sur les comptes, sur la manière dont le projet se développe.
Vraiment, le business, c'est pas tellement l'éditorial.
Voilà.
Est-ce qu'il faut de la publicité dans Médor ? Ce genre de discussions là, OK. Mais concrètement, ça n'arrive pas tellement.
Puisque tu disais, la coopérative n'est pas vraiment assez développée pour que ces discussions puissent avoir lieu.
C'est avant tout une coopérative de soutien.
Ouais, c'est ça. Ouais, ouais, ouais. Et au départ, vous aviez cet espoir ?
Alors, il y a des initiatives, comme un média allemand qui s'appelle Krautreporter, qui parvient à utiliser les coopérateurs et les coopératrices, par exemple en leur demandant, de un, où ils sont localisés.
Alors ça, c'est une information que l'on a. Et quels sont leurs sujets où ils ont des compétences spécifiques. Et donc ils ont une base de données incroyable pour à un moment donné,
solliciter de manière assez précise des personnes qui disent : « Moi, j'ai une expérience en tourisme.
» Ils font un papier sur leur tourisme, ils vont chercher dans leur base de données, ils disent : « On a 30 personnes là qui s'identifient comme experts. »
On n'a jamais mis ça en place de notre côté. Et à partir du moment où on n'a pas cherché ces compétences chez nos coopérateurs et coopératrices, c'est évident qu'on ne parvient pas à les mobiliser. Le seul moment-
Est-ce que c'est un regret que tu exprimes ou est-ce que...
C'est une limite. Je crois que c'est une limite que j'exprime. C'est sûr qu'on est, j'sais pas, qu'on est assis sur un trésor, mais-
Non, parce que je te présente, quand on parle de la coopérative, tu dis : « Bon, ben finalement, les coopérateurs, c'est surtout une forme de soutien.
Les coopérateurs, bon, chez Cross Reporter, ils arrivent à faire quelque chose avec ça, nous, pas tellement. » Donc,
c'est pour ça que je demande s'il y a une forme de regret dans ce que tu exprimes ici ou bien si c'est un choix assumé de dire : « Bah non, on ne veut pas tout ça. »
Alors, c'est pas un regret. C'est donc à la fois le fait de dire, ça reste la forme qui devait être utilisée pour créer Médor et qui ensuite a été reprise par d'autres.
On a clairement des limites par rapport à l'exploitation de ce que l'on pourrait faire avec les personnes qui nous soutiennent.
Et c'est pas un regret, mais à ce stade-ci, c'est un choix pragmatique. Si on dédie trois personnes à l'animation de cette
coopérative, ce qui me semble un minimum pour 1 900 personnes, si on veut le faire bien, correctement,
avec de vrais échanges structurés, à ce moment-là, ces trois personnes, c'est les trois personnes qui s'occupent ici de l'abonnement, de l'administratif, des factures, de la promo, de la com.
Et donc, on va devoir retirer toutes ces fonctions. En fait, c'est-
C'est pragmatique.
Il n'y a pas de choix possible, en fait, par rapport à la situation de Médor. On a trois personnes qui sont employées.
C'est impossible dans l'état actuel des choses d'en dégager une ou de créer un ou deux nouveaux postes pour animer la coopérative.
Et donc, de façon très pragmatique, puisque tu constates que ce n'est pas possible, vous constatez que c'est inatteignable.
Du coup, pas de regret. C'est ça que tu dis ?
Oui.
Voilà, ouais, OK, OK. C'est très, très pragmatique, très lucide. Maintenant, revenons aux origines en 2012. Tu--
sur toutes ces années, qu'est-ce qui, quels sont les articles et quelles sont les enquêtes qui t'ont marqué, dont tu te souviens le plus ?
Si je te demande les greatest hits te concernant personnellement, hein, sur lesquels tu as pu travailler et qui t'ont marqué humainement.
Ben, y a forcément le lancement de Médor, donc la première enquête, qui traitait d'une entreprise pharmaceutique liégeoise, Mithra.
Un article qui était rédigé par David Leloup. Donc c'était dans le premier numéro. Il se fait que Mithra nous a attaqués en justice.
Y a une procédure qui fait que la justice a empêché à un moment donné Médor de sortir. Et cette enquête m'a forcément marqué.
Alors, le contenu était remarquable, mais c'était aussi l'effet que ça a provoqué. Donc, on a eu des huissiers de justice qui sont venus sonner à nos portes.
On a eu un risque d'amende qui montait jusqu'à 500 000 euros pour le premier numéro. On a une mobilisation autour de nous.
On a vu à quel point le fait d'avoir réfléchi le projet pendant trois ans nous rendait extrêmement robustes et cohérents dans la manière dont on présentait le projet, alors que c'était notre premier numéro.
Donc, ça a été évidemment quelque chose de très, de très marquant.
C'est pour ça que tu dis 2012 ? Parce que donc Médor, fondé en 2015.
Donc, Médor a trois dates de naissance, Julien. Il y a une première date, c'est en août 2012. C'est la première réunion de personnes qui se disent : « Tiens, on ferait bien un truc ».
OK.
Et on se réunit autour d'un spaghett' bolo et on se dit : « Qu'est-ce qu'on ferait ? » Ça, c'est au mois d'août 2012, je me souviens plus de la date exacte.
Et puis, y a le 4, au bout de deux ans de réflexion et d'échange, y a la création de la coopérative qui est le 4 juillet 2014.
C'est ça, ouais.
Et au moment où la coopérative est créée-
Donc c'est vraiment, c'est maintenant que-
Donc ça, c'était y a-- ça, c'est les 10 ans.
Ouais, ouais.
Mais on va encore faire les 10 ans l'année prochaine de Médor. Parce qu'une fois que la coopérative a été créée, on a pris nos bâtons de pèlerin et on-
J'avais pas calculé le timing pour les 10 ans, mais on va dire que j'ai calculé le timing.
Voilà.
Mais j'ai absolument calculé le timing. Ce n'est pas une coïncidence.
Et donc, juillet 2014, c'est bel et bien la naissance de la coopérative. Et puis, quand la coopérative naît, on prend notre bâton de pèlerin, on est une quinzaine de personnes
et on va voir des gens en leur disant : « Est-ce que vous voulez soit rentrer dans la coopérative, soit vous abonner au projet ?
» Parce que nous, on va pas travailler bénévolement. Donc, on a besoin déjà d'un soutien financier. Et au bout d'un an, on avait suffisamment d'argent pour faire deux numéros.
Et on a lancé le premier numéro de Médor, il sort, je pense, en novembre 2015. Ce pourquoi on va encore fêter nos 10 ans l'année prochaine.
Donc, et parce qu'on aime bien faire des fêtes aussi.
Bah oui, je m'en doute. Et donc pour revenir, pardon, je t'ai interrompu, mais donc sur ce, est-ce que tu appellerais ça une procédure bâillon, la pression qui a été exercée par ce groupe pharmaceutique ?
C'était très clairement une procédure bâillon. C'était la volonté de nous empêcher de sortir sous un argument qui nous paraissait complètement aberrant, c'est-à-dire que l'article allait avoir un impact sur la
santé économique de l'entreprise pharmaceutique.
Mh.
Ce qui, en gros, fait que plus aucune enquête, alors plus aucune investigation ne pourrait sortir.
Oui, ça ne peut impacter négativement personne.
Donc heureusement, la justice nous a donné en tout cas raison sur la forme, c'était hors de question de nous interdire la sortie.
Donc à ce moment-là, le titre a été vraiment revendu, où on espérait trois mille, quatre mille ventes, on en a atteint dix mille.
Donc ça a lancé véritablement le projet. Voilà. Sinon dans les enquêtes qui ont marqué, ou les sujets qui ont marqué, moi, je--
en récit, j'ai beaucoup aimé
le récit d'Anne Cécile Huard sur Madame Martin, qui est sa voisine, qui est atteinte d'un syndrome de Gilles de la Tourette, mais qui-- ça parle de solitude, de solitude de personnes âgées en milieu urbain.
Il se fait que sa voisine décède et que le récit continue pour voir à un moment donné à quel point on s'en rend compte, à quel moment, quels sont les métiers qui interviennent dans l'accompagnement de ces gens qui n'ont jamais été accompagnés.
Et pourquoi est-ce que cette enquête t'a marqué ? Qu'est-ce qui-
Alors, c'est pas une enquête, là, enfin, je-
Oui, bon-
Je dirais plutôt un récit.
Voilà, oui.
Parce que-
En anglais, on dirait « it's a story ».
Ouais, bon, on va éviter ça. Parce que ça, ça touche au Graal journalistique selon moi qui est de, à travers le singulier, réussir à raconter l'universel ou à nous raconter en fait.
À travers Madame Martin,
on raconte des enjeux de société qui sont la vieillesse, la solitude, comment accompagner, comment faire, comment faire société avec des personnes plus âgées, comment faire en sorte que les personnes isolées, si elles ne souhaitent pas l'être,
ne le soient pas.
On peut être solitaire, mais on peut aussi souffrir de solitude. Donc comment faire en sorte que ces personnes
ne soient pas mises sur le côté et qu'on ne découvre pas leur corps comme c'était le cas pour Madame Martin, je pense, trois ou quatre semaines après le décès.
Et donc c'est ce qui m'a marqué, outre la qualité de la narration, c'est ce qui m'a marqué, c'est-- ou ce qui me touche, c'est cette capacité à un moment donné à nous raconter à travers des histoires singulières.
Vraiment l'empathie, on touche à quelque chose d'humain, de profondément universel comme tu dis.
Oui. Et je pourrais aussi citer l'article d'Eric Walravens où il nous avait parlé de sa volonté de parler de la réinsertion de personnes prisonniers.
Et on dit OK, mais il faut que tu trouves une méthode, comment on va raconter. Il a mis deux ans pour trouver des contacts, pour avoir l'autorisation de se retrouver à un moment donné au parloir avec un prisonnier.
Et le récit se passe pendant huit rencontres où il discute avec ce prisonnier. On n'est jamais dans quelque chose qui est très théorisant sur la réinsertion.
On reste très proche de ce personnage,
et on comprend que ça va pas fonctionner parce qu'il a vécu une grande partie de son existence en prison, de récidive en récidive, il se retrouve incarcéré et lui-même le dit : « Dès que je vais ressortir,
y a quand même beaucoup de chances que je revienne en prison ».
Et on voit, à travers son parcours et à travers la qualité aussi du récit d'Eric, on voit à quel point, à un moment donné, la réinsertion est un défi de longue haleine qui demande aussi beaucoup d'accompagnement, de structure.
Très souvent dans la ligne éditoriale de Médor, finalement, on retrouve les sujets dont personne n'a vraiment envie de parler, les questions un petit peu embarrassantes hein, finalement, de qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec la vieillesse ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les personnes à réinsérer dans la société après une peine de prison ? C'est des choses dont les gens sont pas forcément hyper à l'aise.
Alors, je pense que nous sommes quand même beaucoup de médias à le traiter. Je crois que dans les deux sujets que je viens de mentionner, c'est l'approche aussi qui fait à un moment donné-
Je disais pas que c'était spécifique à Médor, mais ça fait partie de l'ADN.
Oui, oui, oui. Oui, oui. Je crois que ça fait partie de l'ADN aussi du journalisme. C'est qu'à un moment donné, c'est de raconter la marge, raconter les périphéries pour réfléchir.
Parce que si on raconte toujours le centre, en fait, le centre a toujours la parole. Les dominants ont toujours la parole.
Donc je crois que ce qui caractérise aussi peut-être Médor, c'est que je crois que pour finir, on s'intéresse peu au pouvoir.
Je crois qu'on s'intéresse peu aux gens qui ont le pouvoir.
Donc est-ce qu'il faut comprendre que alors les personnes qui travaillent dans la presse et qui couvrent le centre, le pouvoir, qui ne vont pas aller chercher du côté des marginaux, du côté de ceux dont on ne parle pas,
on a presque envie de-- on entend presque dans ce que tu dis que ce ne sont pas vraiment des journalistes, c'est un peu ta conviction ?
Ouh là, pas du tout. Non, non.
Parce que tu dis, le journalisme est défini par ça. Oui, je te provoque un peu.
Je fais exprès de toujours un petit peu mal comprendre ce que tu dis, mais tu exprimes que c'est une exigence dans le journalisme de travailler de cette manière.
Non, non. C'est une exigence dans notre journalisme-
Oui, c'est ça.
Dans le journalisme de Médor, mais qui est un journalisme qui est le journalisme de Florence Aubenas.
On pourrait même remonter à Nellie Bly et Albert Londres. Mais c'est un journalisme narratif, George Orwell.
C'est un journalisme narratif qui fait qu'à un moment donné, on donne beaucoup de temps, beaucoup de place, beaucoup de densité aux personnes qui en effet étaient en marge ou qui sont dans l'ombre.
C'est un journalisme qui a sa valeur, qui a... Mais par contre, et donc il y a quand même très peu de chances ou de moins en-- je pense qu'on,
par exemple, dédie une interview à des gens qui ont déjà beaucoup la parole médiatique parce qu'on va rien apporter.
Où on va pas apporter grand-chose. Mais par contre, je reviens, c'est un journalisme plus quotidien ou un journalisme d'analyse ou un journalisme hebdomadaire qui pour moi a tout à fait sa place et que je lis et qui me-
Journal de veille, comme tu disais
...et qui me nourrit. Donc, je voudrais surtout pas que tout le monde fasse du Médor ou que sais-je.
J'en ai besoin et je trouve que c'est très bien et que les gens qui, à un moment donné, ces gens de pouvoir, entre guillemets, que nous, on va peut-être moins interroger, je suis ravi de les lire dans d'autres médias.
C'est simplement aujourd'hui, y a-- 'fin, y a sans doute jamais eu une manière de faire du journalisme, mais encore moins aujourd'hui, en fait.
Ce qui est à la fois fascinant et passionnant dans le monde journalistique, c'est ces multiples îlots, ces multiples manières de raconter comme ce que tu fais maintenant.
Je crois qu'il y a 20 ans, ton émission radio ne pouvait sans doute pas exister parce que tu avais besoin d'une plateforme qui allait te relayer.
On allait te demander peut-être des formes d'exigence, est-ce que tu-
Format plus court
...est-ce que tu es journaliste ? Est-ce que tu peux faire un format plus court ? Or, on se rend compte qu'aujourd'hui, pour ce type de format, il y a un public.
D'abord, il y a des plateformes qui existent, il y a des supports qui existent et puis il y a un public qui existe pour un Septante Minutes.
Et que c'est très bien que Septante Minutes Avec existe à côté du journal parlé de la Première ou de France Inter ou que sais-je, qui va être dans un style tout à fait différent.
Au-delà des questions de-- je suis tout à fait d'accord. J'approuve l'existence de Septante Minutes Avec. Personne ne sera surpris.
Au-delà des questions de, voilà, de format, de durée, etc. Y a aussi la question de la ligne éditoriale. Voilà, je--
si, si d'aventure, parfois, je retrouve des membres de ma famille qui habitent à Olliers-Saint-Pierre et que je regarde un petit peu les médias qu'ils consomment,
je vois, et c'est le problème du journalisme, 'fin, le problème de la consommation médiatique depuis
20 ans, mais enfin, ça s'accélère de plus en plus depuis encore plus longtemps que ça, c'est la polarisation.
On vit dans des réalités assez différentes quand on consomme Médor, quand on consomme Septante Minutes Avec et quand on consomme juste, bah, en l'occurrence, c'est pas celui-là, mais c'est News ou Les News ou LN24, etc.
On a un prisme, un regard sur la réalité qui est très différent. Quel est ton regard là-dessus sur l'évolution de cette polarisation et du rôle des médias, par exemple comme Médor, mais aussi les autres ?
L'évolution sur ces 20 dernières années, 10 dernières années.
Mais alors, pour moi, y a deux types de polarisation. Le premier type, qui, je pense, n'est pas encore aussi prégnant en Belgique qui est la polarisation politique
qu'on va retrouver beaucoup plus en France, où on a des médias qui sont beaucoup plus situés.
On tend vers ça tout doucement. Surtout en Flandre et un petit peu en Belgique francophone aussi.
On tend vers ça, c'est vrai. On voit par exemple une La Libre qui se positionne de plus en plus en centre droit, avec des éditos qui
ouvrent en centre droit ou peut-être encore un peu plus à droite avec des éditos qui assument clairement cette-- en tout cas, à travers les éditoriaux, on voit des-
Pour être très très concret, on parle de, voilà, de la une, 'fin, la home de
LaLibre.be avec des extraits d'interviews qui disent en grand : « La gauche va détruire ce pays » ou bien, ou bien ensuite, y a l'histoire avec,
le PTB, le PS et Écolo qui avaient voté pour
retarder, disons, la réforme Glatigny.
Y avait vraiment des dizaines d'articles, d'éditos, etc., pour expliquer que c'était la catastrophe absolue, que le PTB était une force destructrice de notre société, etc.
Donc voilà, une ligne de plus en plus assumée, effectivement. Quand j'avais interviewé Frédéric Chardon il y a cinq ans, le temps passe, voilà, il présentait ça comme étant un journal pro-business, voilà.
Je pense que ça a encore un petit peu évolué au niveau de la ligne éditoriale depuis, voilà. Et autre exemple que j'ai en tête pour terminer la remise en contexte de ce que tu dis,
c'est-- parce que tu parlais des paris sportifs tout à l'heure.
On connaît les proximités de certaines figures politiques, par exemple Georges-Louis Bouchez,
avec ces enjeux-là. Et on sait qu'effectivement, du côté d'IPM, c'est compliqué d'écrire des articles qui vont un petit peu critiquer ou dénoncer les choses,
du côté du pouvoir et spécifiquement le pouvoir du président du Mouvement Réformateur.
Mais donc, en effet, au niveau politique, y a peut-être une plus grande polarisation.
Qu'autrefois, oui, mais pas autant qu'en France.
Qu'autrefois, pas autant qu'en France. Et aussi, je pense que le journalisme est là le reflet de la société d'un moment donné, d'une polarisation aussi dans les discours au niveau politique.
Les corps intermédiaires sont de plus en plus malmenés, qu'on parle du monde associatif, du monde syndical ou de la presse ou même de la justice, la police.
On sent que tout ce qui incarne à un moment donné une forme de pouvoir est mis à mal, pour de bonnes raisons et parfois de moins bonnes.
Donc le journalisme participe à ça. Et puis y a quand même une autre forme de polarisation. C'est, on a des gens qui sont surinformés, bien informés, qui vont acheter quatre magazines, qui vont lire
trois quotidiens et qui sont abonnés par ailleurs à deux podcasts qu'ils vont suivre.
Et puis y a cette fracture informationnelle avec des gens qui, à l'inverse, fonctionnent beaucoup aux titres-
Aux intuitions, à leurs intuitions, à leurs convictions qui ont été sculptées, qui ont été formées par le JT de RTL-TVI ou par juste l'environnement dans lequel ils ont grandi.
Et avec une forme de journalisme, toute même médiocre parce qu'on est dans une situation financière qui-- des conditions de travail qui sont particulièrement difficiles.
Je pense que le journalisme local est en grande souffrance, un peu partout, mais certainement en Belgique,
avec les peu de pigistes qui restent, qui sont payés peau de chagrin et qui, du coup, dans des situations pareilles, vous pouvez mettre le ou la meilleure journaliste
fera un travail médiocre parce que le cadre de travail est médiocre.
Et des gens, du coup, se nourrissent avec ce type de journalisme et on a une grande fracture entre des médias,
bah comme Médor ou d'autres qui vont prendre leur temps,
qui m'ont-- on va pas spécialement en termes financiers être dans de grandes conditions, mais par contre, sur le temps, l'accompagnement, l'attention éditoriale et l'attention d'écriture et d'information,
il va y avoir un processus qui va faire qu'on va se retrouver avec un journalisme qui va très vite
et qui fait parfois des erreurs.
On-- il suffit de lire les décisions du Conseil de déontologie journalistique pour voir parfois les manquements à la déontologie à cause justement de cette rapidité.
Et puis, on a des magazines qui se-- ou des projets hein, parce que des projets éditoriaux qui s'inscrivent dans des temps beaucoup plus longs et dans de l'investigation.
Et là, on a aussi une fracture et je pense que cette fracture existe aussi au sein des rédactions. On voit dans Le Soir et La Libre, par exemple, qu'il y a des pôles investigation qui sont mis en avant.
Je crains qu'à côté de ces pôles où les gens travaillent sur des projets longs, il y ait des journalistes qui sont plutôt des journalistes qu'on va appeler desk,
qui traitent beaucoup de la dépêche et qui doivent par ailleurs remplir de plus en plus le journal.
Tu citais il y a quelques instants le Conseil de déontologie. Quel regard est-ce que tu portes sur le Conseil de déontologie journalistique aujourd'hui en Belgique ?
Est-ce que tu en es satisfait de, voilà, ils se réunissent de façon régulière, ils portent des décisions sur des contingents, des conflits, des-- voilà, la déontologie de certains journalistes qui sont remises en question.
Est-ce que tu es satisfait du travail du Conseil de déontologie journalistique aujourd'hui ?
Alors moi, je trouve que c'est un formidable outil. Donc c'est-
En théorie, en pratique ou tu le constates ?
En théorie et en pratique.
Ok.
Pour moi, il donne véritablement un cadre de travail. C'est
un organe aussi qui nous donne beaucoup de liberté parce qu'il nous explique, par exemple, quand on peut mentir en tant que journaliste, ce qui est quand même assez exceptionnel.
Donc, par exemple, quand on veut travailler en immersion, il y a un article du Code de déontologie journalistique qui donne précisément dans quel cadre on peut ne pas dévoiler son identité journalistique.
Ils émettent aussi des directives pour voir comment protéger des publics plus fragilisés, type les mineurs, ou des personnes, ou comment traiter les questions de genre.
Et je crois que c'est quand même, ça manquait dans la profession et notamment pour les indépendants, d'avoir ce type de support qui nous permette de dire comment pratiquer le journalisme.
Parce que pour finir, les écoles nous apprennent le contexte de l'information, le contexte politique, des techniques, véritablement dans le sens technique de prise de vue ou...
Mais toute la question de déontologie, comment approcher à un moment donné une personne, si elle est fragilisée, si elle n'a pas conscience des médias, comment faire en sorte que,
qu'elle soit consciente de ce qui va se passer, comment avoir un consentement éclairé, comment gérer l'anonymat.
Ça pose un cadre et ça vous aide à ne pas faire de bavure à ce niveau-là ?
Moi, je trou-- oui, ça pose un cadre, ça nous aide à ne pas faire de bavure, ça nous aide à avoir des procédures, ça nous aide à respecter le droit de réplique, ça nous aide,
euh-- pour moi, je lis de temps en temps des décisions du Conseil de déontologie journalistique.
Je vois la pratique d'autres journalistes,
ce qui ne signifie pas de dire des bons ou des mauvais journalistes, mais d'identifier à un moment donné des situations de contexte qui sont toujours des situations singulières et qui font que,
des articles du code, à un moment donné, n'ont pas, mais c'est pas juste des articles du code, c'est le respect, à un moment donné aussi, des personnes n'a pas été effectif.
Ok. Et aucune critique, aucune frustration par rapport à leur travail ?
Bah de manière globale, on pourrait critiquer le fait que c'est du corporatisme, évidemment, puisque c'est pour finir des journalistes.
Alors, il y a un peu plus, c'est des éditeurs de la société civile, mais qui jugent les journalistes. Donc, on pourrait juger que c'est de l'entre-soi, c'est de l'autorégulation.
Ce serait dans un autre secteur, je pense que je serais le premier à le critiquer si des chocolatiers jugeaient des chocolatiers.
Donc là, on a quelque chose de-- c'est le système qu'il faut requestionner. Sinon, je pense que ce serait bien qu'il soit renforcé pour que les décisions soient plus rapides.
Ça, ça ne relève pas du Conseil de déontologie journalistique. Et parce que toi, tu as des critiques par rapport au Conseil de déontologie, j'imagine.
T'essayes de m'amener quelque part, là.
Bah, précisément, bah, je suis forcément biaisé, hein, mais c'est--
je-- est-ce que je ne dis pas une bêtise ? Tu as-- je pense que tu connais Septante Minutes Avec parce que tu as écouté l'interview de Myriam, non, il y a cinq ans, ouais.
Bon, Myriam a eu quelques déboires avec le CDJ, notamment un certain blogueur qui l'attaque, la calomnie, certains diraient, je vais parler au conditionnel.
Et là, le CDJ a dit : « Bah finalement, enfin,
ça ne dépasse pas les règles, quoi. Ça passe. » Et là, j'ai senti-- bon, donc je pose la question sans avoir, malgré les apparences, sans avoir une idée de la réponse, de : est-ce qu'il y a un problème à ce niveau-là ?
Parce que la presse est très protégée en Belgique, le fameux délit de presse qui date déjà du XIXe siècle. Fait que voilà, dans certains cas, et c'est--
quand je dis certains cas, ça couvre donc également les blogueurs, les tweets, etc., qui des fois, là, ça pose question de : est-ce que la presse n'est pas un petit peu trop protégée ?
Est-ce que les règles ne sont pas un petit peu trop permissives ?
Ben, je connais pas le cas particulier. J'ai pas lu la décision concernant cette affaire particulière. C'est toujours-- moi, je pense que
sans doute avec des manquements, aujourd'hui, avoir cette institution qui
observe le journalisme et qui est le garant, peut-être parfois maladroit ou incomplet, mais de ce code de déontologie et qui le nourrit et qui le fait évoluer, ça me paraît, c'est évident que c'est une avancée pour la profession.
Donc ça, c'est en théorie. Mais donc, tu dis en pratique, tu n'as pas constaté de manquement à ce niveau-là.
Et en pratique, ça fonctionne. Je vais pas dire que chaque décision est une bonne décision.
Et après, même quand le conseil juge qu'il y a un manquement ou qu'il y a un problème, finalement, il n'y a pas vraiment de sanction.
C'est pas comme s'il y avait une amende, que l'auteur, l'autrice était pénalisé pour ça.
Alors, il y a un double regard parce qu'il n'y a pas d'amende financière, ou de privation à un moment donné de pouvoir exercer en tant que journaliste.
Donc on n'est pas impacté directement.
Ouais, mais dans un secteur précaire, on devient un mouton noir, peut-être.
Tous les journalistes vont être attentifs à la décision du Conseil de déontologie, parce que s'il y a bien une chose qui nous est précieuse et que l'on essaye de chérir, c'est notre crédibilité.
Si demain je me fais sept fois crosser par le Conseil de déontologie journalistique, c'est évident que les gens vont quand même commencer à se questionner sur à la fois ma méthodo et du coup la pertinence de me lire.
Donc il y a quand même une force symbolique qui n'est pas négligeable dans notre métier.
Ouais, ouais. On parlait donc de l'évolution de la presse ces dix, vingt dernières années, la polarisation, et on parlait de finalement, une des choses, un des constats sur lesquels Médor s'est basé pour se lancer, c'est,
à l'époque en tout cas, l'absence de plateforme pour le journalisme d'investigation qui est vraiment au cœur de Médor.
Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui, tu trouves que ça a évolué ? Est-ce que le journalisme d'investigation se porte mieux, voire bien en Belgique francophone ?
Alors...
Grâce à Médor.
Alors, pas grâce à Médor, mais le journalisme d'investigation en Belgique francophone se porte mieux qu'il y a quinze ans.
Moi, ça me paraît une évidence. Il y a plusieurs choses par rapport à ça. C'est que
il y a eu un élément important, ça a été la naissance
d'un fonds pour le journalisme qui, à un moment donné, a permis à des journalistes indépendants ou salariés d'obtenir une somme suffisante pour travailler sur des sujets de société en Belgique.
Tu parles des aides à la presse, spécifiquement ?
Non, je parle du fonds pour le journalisme-
D'accord
...qui permet, tous les quatre à cinq fois par an, on peut déposer un projet et si ce projet est financé, soutenu, on reçoit une somme alors estimable, en tout cas pour le milieu journalistique, qui va être
avoisinée entre cinq et quinze mille euros, pour avoir une fourchette large, et qui va permettre soit à un journaliste salarié de travailler sur ce sujet sur le long terme, ou à un indépendant de travailler dessus.
Ça a permis à des gens, dont moi, de rester dans la profession. C'est évident. C'est devenu à un moment donné une source qui nous a permis de travailler pendant trois mois, six mois, un an sur un sujet.
Ce fonds existe donc depuis, je pense, une quinzaine d'années. Il y a eu la cellule investigation qui a été créée au Soir.
Il y a une cellule investigation qui a été créée à la RTBF. Il y a une cellule investigation qui vient à l'instant d'être créée, je crois, chez IPM.
On a, pendant quinze ans, on a tout doucement abandonné cette frénésie du web qui était, à mon avis, l'âge adolescent du journalisme où on devait publier beaucoup.
Je me souviens que les médias créaient des newsletters quasi toutes les heures. Il y avait des rendez-vous qui étaient multipliés sur vingt-quatre heures parce qu'il fallait
assumer ce flot continu qui mettait une pression terrible sur le journalisme.
C'est quelque chose dont, je pense, les rédactions sont revenues, où de plus en plus, ils essayent de dicter elles-mêmes le tempo et la ligne éditoriale du média, quitte à abandonner certains sujets.
Et le journalisme d'investigation permet d'apporter, de se distinguer des autres médias, d'apporter ses propres ressources, qui fait qu'on va sur Le Soir et pas chez IPM parce que c'est Le Soir qui a l'info sur le sujet.
Tout à fait. Le Soir a créé une cellule d'investigation qui a quand même sorti beaucoup de...
Sur Nethys, par exemple.
D'enquêtes. Sur Nethys, alors, c'est tout de même Cédric Alain qui contacte David Leloup, qui, suite à un article dans Médor, publie ensuite l'affaire Nethys dans Le Vif et puis ça commence à exploser à ce moment-là.
Ok, mais c'était pas Le Soir ?
De mémoire, c'était pas Le Soir.
Ok, ok. Attends pour-
Mais par contre, Le Soir a sorti, ne serait-ce que récemment, Qatar Gate ou toute une série d'enquêtes. Et aussi,
si on en revient de manière plus globale au journalisme d'investigation, il y a ce consortium dans lequel Le Soir participe,
qui permet aussi de travailler sur des sujets internationaux, de travailler sur des gros dossiers.
Nous, avec Le Soir, on a travaillé sur Open Pharma, c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment donné, on a une base de données nettoyée sur les liens entre entreprises pharmaceutiques et toute une série de praticiens dans le secteur de la santé.
Et ça nous a permis de travailler en collaboration avec The Tate, L'Écho et Le Soir et Médor. Et donc on voit qu'il y a des nouvelles pratiques aussi d'investigation qui arrivent, donc
Par rapport à il y a quinze ans, moi, c'est évident qu'aujourd'hui, on a, je pense, un meilleur journalisme.
On a peut-être un pire aussi, mais je pense qu'on a un meilleur journalisme d'investigation qu'il y a quinze ans, oui.
Mh. On parle beaucoup de, voilà, différents titres de presse, hein, depuis tout à l'heure. On fait un petit peu le tour du paysage médiatique ici en Belgique.
Quand j'avais interviewé Alice Coffin, elle me faisait remarquer que dans son pays, dans son lointain pays, la culture du journalisme média était très peu présente, que finalement,
les journalistes qui parlent du journalisme, hein, encore une forme d'entre soi finalement, ça n'était pas bien vu, critiquer le travail des confrères, c'est aussi très mal vu, etc.
Est-ce que le journalisme média, c'est quelque chose qui intéresse Médor ? Est-ce que ça se porte bien en Belgique, tu dirais ?
Donc tu veux dire du journalisme qui a pour sujet le journalisme ou les autres médias-
C'est ça. Par exemple, parler de ce qu'on disait il y a quelques instants sur, voilà, le-- alors, c'est la famille Lahoud qui a le contrôle sur IPM et qui, voilà, installe une certaine ligne éditoriale.
Est-ce qu'on pourrait comparer ça à une polarisation en France ? Je ne sais pas, mais voilà, il y a des choses à explorer, hein.
Les articles qui ne peuvent pas être publiés chez IPM. Il y a peut-être des choses à dire à ce niveau-là. Est-ce que le journalisme média est quelque chose qui intéresse Médor ou pas du tout ?
Alors, je vais te répondre, il y a un article dans le code de déontologie qui
dit qu'on doit traiter nos consœurs et confrères avec justement confraternité, une attention qui est, je pense, le seul article du code de déontologie que je refuse de suivre.
C'est très restrictif, hein.
Oui, c'est-- t'as à un moment donné, même si, voilà, tout en précisant qu'on a le droit évidemment, j'espère, d'enquêter sur d'autres médias.
Mais ce dont tu parles, c'est véritablement pour moi la tache aveugle du journalisme en Belgique, c'est-à-dire qu'on n'a pas de médias sérieux ou on n'a pas de journalistes qui, à un moment donné, traitent
sur les autres médias.
Et, mais dans une manière juste-- dans un politique au sens large du terme, c'est-à-dire en analysant véritablement les groupes médiatiques, en se permettant à un moment des analyses sur Rossel, des analyses sur les liens entre IPM et Betfirst.
Bon, les liens étaient évidents, mais de voir comment ça modifie la rédaction, je pense qu'on pourrait citer d'autres, LN24, comment LN24 se comporte.
On pourrait interroger la RTBF, travailler sur ce conseil d'administration, sur la manière dont on gère à un moment donné des influences. Pourquoi pas,
du moment que c'est fait avec une démarche journalistique. Est-ce que c'est dû à
l'étroitesse du territoire qui fait qu'on se connaît tous et toutes et qui empêche à un moment donné d'aller regarder dans le jardin de l'autre ?
Mais c'est en tout cas un manquement. Et tu disais par rapport à Médor, est-ce que c'est quelque chose que l'on devrait faire ?
C'est quelque chose que l'on a fait.
On a quand même traité des sujets qui sont liés aux médias. Je me souviens qu'on a fait un papier qui s'appelait La Crève, qui évoquait les conditions de travail autour des séries télévisées type La Trêve de la RTBF.
On a fait un sujet sur-
Donc ça, c'est pas la presse alors.
Alors là, c'était le-- non, c'était la RTBF, le média. Ça, c'est vrai que c'était moins la presse, mais on a traité La Libre et ses relations avec Betfirst.
On a traité par ailleurs IPM et son rapport au numérique. On a évoqué les piges des journalistes indépendants locaux.
Donc, on en a fait quand même, mais on n'en a pas fait assez. C'est quelque chose sur lequel on voudrait travailler plus, c'est sur le monde médiatique.
Et par exemple, donc tu disais peut-être que c'est l'étroitesse du territoire. Est-ce que du coup, vos relations avec ces médias-là, par exemple donc IPM, est-ce qu'elles se sont vues détériorées ?
Est-ce que vous êtes devenu persona non grata parce que vous avez parlé de Betfirst et de...
Bah déjà, je sais pas si on était persona grata tout court. Honnêtement, je n'en sais rien parce que-
Il t'est arrivé d'être invité sur LN24 encore.
Mais je-- bah relativement peu, mais je cours pas après les invitations. Je suis pas un super client.
Non, mais je veux dire persona grata du coup.
Ah oui, oui, donc j'ai-- oui, oui, je pense qu'il y a pas-- je ne crois pas qu'il y a une forme d'omerta ou de consigne pour empêcher Médor à un moment donné d'exister.
Certainement pas. Par ailleurs, les journalistes d'IPM sont comme d'autres journalistes, c'est pas à eux qu'on va la faire.
Donc, même s'il y a une consigne de la direction, ça m'étonnerait qu'elle soit respectée. Ils peuvent être éventuellement heurtés qu'on attaque entre guillemets leur groupe.
Mais de là à ce que ça amène une consigne pour empêcher un titre d'exister dans l'univers médiatique, ça, j'y crois pas du tout.
Oui, oui. Ces penchements idéologiques, éditoriaux alors se font peut-être plus sur les sphères supérieures alors, dans le management et pas tellement au sein de la rédaction.
Certainement. Ça, je crois que c'est de manière globale dans les médias,
s'il y a à un moment donné des accointances avec le monde politique ou le monde économique, je pense que ça se passe à un niveau, à l'étage au-dessus en fait des journalistes.
Je sais pas pourquoi, parce qu'effectivement, comme tu dis, l'étroitesse du territoire fait que j'ai presque pas envie de citer des noms, mais je vais le faire.
Est-ce que, voilà, au sein de la rédaction de La Libre, Dorian Demeusse n'a pas activement lui-même des convictions qui font que ça penche d'un certain côté politiquement ?
Ouais, il est rédacteur en chef de La Libre. Donc il est le-
Il fait des éditos
Il est le capitaine du navire, il fait des éditos. Il est sans doute aussi la charnière entre la direction et ses équipes rédactionnelles.
Donc il est à sa place en faisant des éditos, il donne-
Et il est choisi donc par le management
Il est choisi par le management et il donne une direction à un moment donné à La Libre, il est totalement dans son rôle.
Oui, bien sûr
Là-dessus, on peut après considérer qu'on n'est pas en phase avec ses prises de position, mais par contre, on peut pas lui dire qu'il n'est pas légitime de donner des impulsions.
Parce que tu disais, ça se passe dans les sphères supérieures, mais ça se répercute indirectement ou directement sur la salle de rédaction malgré tout.
Voilà, donc pas assez de journalisme média, effectivement. Parce que concrètement, c'est... Voilà, je-- en parlant off avec des journalistes ou même des employés de groupes médias, etc.
Il y a des infos qui surgissent sur des articles qui n'ont pas pu être publiés, sur des proximités publicitaires avec certains partis, sur certains sites, etc.
Et on se dit : Mais il y a quelque chose à dire là-dessus. Et en fait, on ne dit pas, on n'en parle pas.
On ne dit pas, c'est vrai.
je pense qu'en effet, qu'il y a des sujets, des pressions, des liens, puisque là, on parlait de pouvoir, entre pouvoir économique, pouvoir politique et pouvoir médiatique qui devraient être racontés et qui ne le sont pas.
Je te rejoins tout à fait.
Du coup, pour continuer sur cette discussion-là, c'était-- on dévie très fort de Médor du coup, puisqu'on parle de médias très différents, mais est-ce que,
voilà, puisque donc le groupe IPM s'est très fort élargi, hein, donc au départ La Libre et puis La Dernière Heure et puis LN24 et puis plus récemment Moustique.
Est-ce que c'est quel-, puisque donc on l'a dit plusieurs fois, un groupe qui a un pansement idéologique assez clair, est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui
te fait réfléchir, qui t'inquiète, que tu trouves problématique ou bien est-ce que c'est juste ?
Voilà, c'est les médias, c'est le reflet de la société, c'est...
Je crois qu'il y a quelque chose de nouveau qui se passe dans la société belge avec lequel on peut être en accord ou pas, c'est l'émergence d'une société de centre-droite ou de droite qui s'affirme, qui s'affirme à travers-
On l'a vu avec l'état d'insurrection.
Voilà, et qui s'affirme notamment à travers les divers corps intermédiaires, dont les médias. Au niveau démocratique, ça n'est pas un problème puisqu'il faut développer cette culture de débat entre les différents éléments.
Je ne suis pas en train de dire le centre-droit, la droite est un problème en soi.
L'autre chose, c'est-
C'est plutôt au niveau médiatique, le déséquilibre, le déséquilibre des forces en fait.
Il y a deux choses,
c'est de savoir si en effet, ce groupe est véritablement infiltré par un parti, ce qui serait profondément problématique, c'est que d'avoir un journalisme qui n'est pas à ce moment-là indépendant.
Je n'ai pas dit infiltré par un parti, mais j'ai dit qui penche très fortement d'un côté quoi.
Qui est influencé, ouais. Et l'autre chose pour moi, c'est-
Qui cherche à aider parce que, peut-être, et là, je spécule, je précise, peut-être certains intérêts pro-business dans le management penchent d'un certain côté. Je spécule.
Oui. La question pour moi qui m'occupe, c'est la question de la concentration.
Mh.
Là, par contre, ça peut devenir inquiétant d'avoir un groupe qui prend de plus en plus la main sur un titre de presse locale, un titre de presse nationale, une TV, un hebdo.
C'est quelque chose auquel on doit être vigilant, pour lequel, si je ne me trompe, la Fédération des journalistes européens a tiré à un moment donné la sonnette d'alarme sur des concentrations de pouvoir.
Et je pense qu'on doit être attentif à ça. Je crois que la meilleure manière de protéger à un moment donné et de renforcer le débat d'idées, c'est d'assurer qu'il y ait cette pluralité, cette diversité, malgré nous ou parfois contre nous.
Et c'est surtout sur ce point-là, à moins que je-- dans le monde médiatique et le monde journalistique, c'est ce point-là sur lequel je voudrais être attentif, en fait.
Parce que donc, il y aurait peut-être des postes qui seraient supprimés éventuellement et qui, on se retrouverait avec le même journaliste politique pour la DH et pour La Libre, ce qui est déjà le cas.
Mh.
Et puis peut-être aussi pour Moustique et puis peut-être aussi pour LN24. Et du coup, ça fait moins de pluralité, moins de postes à pourvoir, plus de précarité.
Oui, c'est évident que ça, c'est un des risques qui menace le journalisme en Belgique.
Donc sur les dix ans ou les douze ans de Médor, selon l'anniversaire qu'on choisit, est-ce que, en rétrospective, tu vois des erreurs ?
Est-ce qu'il y a des choix qui ont été faits ou que tu regrettes amèrement encore aujourd'hui ? Ou bien est-ce que vous avez tout géré depuis le début, dix sur dix ?
Alors fondamentalement, je ne regrette aucun choix. Je-- on a fait des erreurs, évidemment, ou en tout cas, on a des échecs.
Mh.
Ça, c'est clair.
Maintenant, le projet a mûri pendant trois ans.
On a fait pendant trois ans des discussions. Médor est un des rares titres qui n'a pas changé de nom, qui n'a pas changé de prix, qui n'a pas changé de format, qui n'a pas changé de ligne éditoriale, qui n'a pas changé d'équipe en dix ans.
Pas parce qu'on est meilleur ou plus intelligent, parce que quasi chacune des options qui a été décidée dans Médor a été réfléchie.
Est-ce qu'on a nos têtes en fin de magazine comme Vingt et un qui est quand même une source d'inspiration ?
Est-ce qu'on faisait comme eux ? Non, on l'a pas fait comme eux. C'est un choix, on peut le faire, d'autres le font, mais est-ce qu'on veut mettre le journalisme en-, le journaliste en avant ?
Médor a tout de suite dit non. En fait, on est un collectif. Est-ce qu'on signe nos éditos ? Non. En fait, on est un collectif.
Est-ce qu'on se traite de l'international ? Non. Est-ce qu'on fait un magazine avec un grand format ? Non.
En fait, on veut quelque chose qui se lit dans les chiottes et dans le tram.
Comme les podcasts.
Voilà.
Mais donc là, tu réponds surtout sur la coopérative, le format. Je peux élargir ma question aussi aux articles, aux enquêtes que tu as pilotées.
Est-ce qu'il y a des choses où tu te dis : « Là, on est passé à côté de quelque chose » ou « on s'est plantés » ?
Non, par contre, on s'est plantés, c'est vrai que-- mais au niveau éditorial, je ne vois pas objectivement de moments où je peux dire : « On a fait une énorme erreur journalistique.
Là, on a vraiment été manipulés. » Ça, c'est le-- je n'ai pas une vue exhaustive de tous les articles qui ont été publiés en dix ans, mais j'en vois pas un que je regrette, honnêtement.
Ok.
Ou un pour lequel on aurait fait une erreur. Maintenant, on a testé plein de choses qui ont pas fonctionné. On a plein-- le parcours de Médor est aussi jalonné d'échecs.
On a voulu faire un Médor Tour, où on s'est installés dans des villes avec des budgets pour raconter ces villes, notamment à La Louvière, à Arlon, à Lan, à Huy.
C'était aussi un projet économique. Ça, on s'est complètement plantés. On trouve difficilement notre voie sur le Web, par exemple.
On ne parvient pas à-- je crois qu'on a des difficultés à transposer notre identité sur le Web parce que ce sont-- quand on veut amener quelque chose de
riche et de complexe sur le Web, aujourd'hui, les budgets sont quand même assez conséquents.
Il suffit de parler de data visualisation, de travailler un peu de développement qui fait qu'à un moment donné, on voit que c'est un travail
enrichi et en même temps, l'économie du Web est encore plus difficile que l'économie papier.
Donc là, on ne trouve pas notre voie, on l'a cherchée, on a fait beaucoup de propositions qui ont été peu rencontrées.
Donc ça aussi, ce sont des échecs. Donc aujourd'hui, je pense qu'on a réfléchi à un titre en 2012, enfin de 2012 à 2015, et aujourd'hui, en 2025, ce titre
vit ce que d'autres médias ont vécu, c'est-à-dire qu'on commence à avoir une histoire et on doit se reconfigurer par rapport à 2025 et bientôt peut-être se reconfigurer par rapport à 2030.
Mais on commence à avoir aussi des formes de rigidité ou d'aspects non négociables parce qu'on existe depuis dix ans et que ça nous rend moins adaptables ou moins malléables.
Donc, mais je suis désolé de le dire si ça paraît présomptueux, mais je-
Mais j'ai l'impression que tu n'es pas quelqu'un de manière générale qui-- tu n'exprimes pas régulièrement des regrets.
Tu n'es pas quelqu'un qui voit ses erreurs passées avec regret. Tu te dis : « Bah voilà, j'ai fait cette décision-là à ce moment-là, avec les cartes que j'avais en main à ce niveau-là.
Je referais la même décision, même si c'était pas la bonne. » C'est un peu ça, la vibe que tu m'envoies.
Mais en tout cas que les décisions que l'on a prises, en effet étaient prises dans un contexte et-- on a fait des choix qui étaient, je pense, réfléchis.
On n'a jamais fait de coup de poker ou de me dire : « Waouh, putain, là, on n'aurait pas dû, je sais pas, prendre un tel risque avec Médor, on s'est plantés », on a pris des risques, mais qui étaient des risques réfléchis.
On a eu beaucoup de chance. Et il se fait que malgré tout, avec toute la prudence que l'on doit avoir, Médor existe dix ans plus tard.
C'était quasi inespéré. On nous donnait-- quand on-- donc je le disais, quand on a lancé le numéro, on avait deux années de-- on avait deux numéros, en fait.
On pouvait tenir deux numéros et le troisième devait se financer avec la vente du premier. Donc, on était à hyper flux tendu.
C'était fragile, ouais.
Et je pense que-- alors, je suis désolé, je me répète et je suis dans l'autosatisfaction complète.
Mais tant mieux, tant mieux.
Mais Médor n'a pas changé sa ligne éditoriale, son projet en dix ans. Ça veut quand même dire quelque chose. Et c'est pas juste moi.
Je suis pas à la barre de Médor. Aujourd'hui, je suis derrière le micro, mais tu pourrais avoir dix ou quinze autres personnes de Médor parler.
Tu fais partie des cofondateurs et tu pilotes encore régulièrement-
Oui, oui.
-des enquêtes.
Donc j'ai ma place dans le titre, mais ce que je veux dire par là, c'est que
c'est aussi, il y a des choix qui ont été faits qui ne sont pas les miens, mais que je suis prêt tout à fait à défendre et qu'il y a une force du collectif qui fait que peut-être qu'on est plus intelligents, parfois,
mais plus intelligents-
Ça, c'est effectivement le truc le moins humble qui est dessus.
Oui, mais qu'on est plus intelligents qu'Olivier Bailly tout seul. On n'est pas plus intelligents que les autres médias, mais il y a des choix qui ont été faits qu'Olivier Bailly tout seul n'aurait jamais faits et aurait fait un truc de naze.
Et là, on a eu des intelligences collectives qui nous ont amenés-- enfin tout ce que les graphistes, par exemple, nous ont amenés sur le Creative Commons, sur l'open source,
sur le fait de faire un projet qui avait une valeur aussi, pas juste à travers ce qu'on produisait, mais à travers la manière dont on
dont l'objet s'inscrivait dans la société. Voilà.
Donc ouais, la totalité, le groupe est supérieur à la somme des parties.
Clairement.
Ouais, OK. Une des grandes ambitions aussi de-- on approche la fin de notre entretien. Une des grandes ambitions aussi de ta part et de Médor, c'est que le journalisme, que ces enquêtes puissent avoir un impact,
qu'il puisse y avoir des répercussions intéressantes.
Hum, est-ce que là, tu as le souvenir ? Si on continue dans la satisfaction et la célébration de tes accomplissements ou de vos accomplissements,
est-ce qu'il y a des impacts qui t'ont particulièrement fait plaisir où là, tu t'es dit : « Ça, c'est cool, c'est vraiment cool que j'ai pu
contribuer à ce changement-là. »
Alors-- je pense que l'enquête que l'on a menée sur les violences dans le scoutisme-
Ah ben tiens, c'est à celle-là que je pensais.
C'était assez-- là, c'était-- y avait une forme quand même un peu jouissive dans la réaction des fédérations. Réaction que par ailleurs, je voudrais souligner parce qu'ils ont pas du tout été dans le déni.
C'était un sujet qui les occupait, dont ils étaient au courant. Il fallait sans doute que quelqu'un d'extérieur vienne à un moment donné le pointer pour qu'il y ait peut-être une prise de conscience plus importante.
Mais y a eu à la fois une mobilisation de gens qui ont dit : « En effet, ce dont vous parlez, c'est quelque chose qui existe.
» Donc déjà, ça, c'était aussi dans une forme de journalisme participatif rassurant, de se dire : « On n'est pas tout seul à tenir cette parole.
» Ensuite, de la porter et d'avoir des fédérations qui réagissent par rapport à ça, mettent des dispositifs, engagent une nouvelle personne pour faire des camps de scouts à un moment donné, des endroits,
des safe places, d'avoir des numéros de téléphone qui se
qui se créent ou en tout cas qui se renforcent, qui redeviennent plus visibles.
Ils ont sorti-- ils ont accéléré la sortie d'une brochure pour à un moment donné informer les gens par rapport aux dangers des excès de la totémisation.
Et donc là, on a vraiment eu ce qu'on a quand même assez rarement en journalisme d'investigation, parce qu'y a plein de fois où on tape, je pense juste, mais ça ne réagit pas.
On a eu là une réaction, une vraiment action-réaction. Et c'est vrai qu'à un moment, ça redonne à la fois cœur et envie et foi dans le journalisme d'investigation.
Une petite pluie de dopamine à ce moment-là de-
Ça fait du bien, ouais.
J'imagine, j'imagine. Donc ça, c'était sorti y a un tout petit peu plus d'un an-
Oui.
Je crois juin, juin 2023. Hum, et donc ouais, le-- réaction des parties concernées et amélioration, c'est, ouais, c'est cool.
Petit-- parce que du coup, figure-toi que le scoutisme, c'était justement un truc que j'avais listé depuis longtemps parmi les sujets qui m'intéressent, mais ça a demandé un travail de fond de votre part, hein.
Vous avez fait un mur des plaintes, vous avez collecté beaucoup de témoignages assez choquants, pour la plupart.
Donc vraiment un travail de fond, un travail sur la durée. Vous étiez trois, hein, je pense.
Oui, c'était avec Céline Gauthier et Louis Van Ginnaken.
Mmm-hmm. Hum, et oui, du coup, parce que voilà, ça, c'est typiquement le genre de sujet où moi, en tant que podcasteur avec mon format d'entretien sur le temps long,
j'ai besoin de trouver un ou une experte, sociologue, journaliste, personne concernée directement.
Et du coup, là, forcément, la difficulté que moi, j'ai, c'est que en fait, non, on ne peut pas trouver.
Cet intervenant n'existe pas. Et donc il faut obligatoirement, à ce moment-là, un travail d'enquête, un travail de fond sur la durée.
C'est là que Médor se distingue en fait finalement, parce que
enfin là, c'est moi qui chante vos accomplissements, mais personne d'autre, concrètement, dans un paysage médiatique belge qui aurait pu la faire, cette enquête.
Car rien ne nous empêchait de le traiter, si ce n'est les contraintes logistiques de temps. Or, il se fait que là, on a en effet pu dégager du temps
et aussi créer une méthode pour récolter cette info, parce que c'est pas juste avoir la plainte d'une personne, ne peut pas jeter le discrédit sur des centaines de milliers de personnes qui vivent le scoutisme.
Donc il a fallu quand même que l'on trouve une méthode pour pouvoir avoir un échantillon, un groupe suffisamment représentatif et pour pouvoir dire qu'on était face à quelque chose de structurel.
Oui, établir des patterns. D'ailleurs, ce quelque chose de structurel, comment est-ce que tu le présenterais ?
Puisque j'ai pas pu trouver un expert là-dessus. Comment est-ce que-- qu'est-ce qu'il y avait au fond du problème, selon toi ?
Mais donc, au fond du problème du-- je crois que ça touche à plusieurs éléments. C'est-- y a d'abord la notion de...
Y a plusieurs choses qui sont imbriquées tout de même. Donc y a un rite initiatique de passage qui va impliquer, selon les traditions, une nécessaire souffrance et humiliation,
auquel on va ajouter une forme de masculinité toxique parce que c'est entre mecs, et puis une fragilité qui est liée à l'adolescence.
Et si on met tous ces ingrédients dans la même casserole et qu'on n'a pas quelqu'un qui surveille un tout petit peu le feu, on a en effet des débordements.
Et ces débordements sont plus ou moins acceptés parce que les personnes qui ont traversé ce rite, du coup, valorisent et justifient ce rite.
En gros, parce que j'en ai pris plein la gueule, c'est la logique d'en prendre plein la gueule. Et par ailleurs, je reproduis le fait d'en foutre plein la gueule.
Et s'y a pas un cadre à un moment donné qui reformate
ce rite en disant : « Attendez, attendez. En fait, les valeurs que porte ce rite, qui sont des valeurs d'ouverture, d'inclusion, d'intégration, ne peuvent pas fonctionner avec les violences que l'on nous raconte,
qui marquent profondément les gens.
» Nous, on a eu des personnes qui hésitaient à aller en justice, qui étaient suivies par des psychologues suite à leur passage quand même chez les scouts.
On était dans quelque chose de l'impact individuel qui est extrêmement lourd. Si ça n'est pas pris en considération par une structure, c'est de nouveau la force de la structure à un moment donné
à impulser des comportements et à donner à l'ensemble des comportements individuels à un moment donné des formes de lignes directrices, presque une ligne éditoriale de la totémisation.
Et ça, ça n'existait pas. Il y avait une forme de glissement.
Et le non-dit, le fait qu'on n'ait pas trop envie de le dénoncer, pas trop envie d'en parler, ça vient juste de la perpétuation, ça vient du fait qu'on l'a subi, donc on le perpétue et on ne dénonce pas ?
Et oui, et puis je crois qu'il y a des conflits de loyauté aussi au sein des personnes. Il y a le fait de dire : moi, j'ai passé cinq années merveilleuses en scoutisme, mais ce moment a été traumatisant.
Il y a des sentiments d'appartenance qui sont très forts, en fait, dans ce-- moi, j'ai pas fait les scouts, donc c'est pas quelque chose que j'identifie en particulier, mais on voyait bien que même au niveau individuel,
c'était pas un camp contre un autre.
Les gens qui nous parlaient des violences avaient les deux camps en eux. Ils ai-
Mh.
Bon, ils pouvaient tout à fait défendre le scoutisme, ce qui était par ailleurs très intéressant dans leur parole.
Y compris ce qu'ils avaient subi, y compris le-
Eux, parce qu'ils avaient subi. Eux, parce qu'ils avaient subi. Ils avaient cette intelligence de la nuance à un moment donné de pouvoir, au sein même de leur expérience,
faire un discernement entre ce qui avait été positif et ce qui avait été négatif,
mais ce qui était aussi très riche et très intéressant.
D'habitude, on a des gens qui viennent dénoncer, qui commencent à appartenir à un camp face à un autre.
Mh.
Là, on avait quelque chose qui relevait en plus du psychologique, de la loyauté, de l'appartenance...
Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas aussi une dimension idéologique ? Puisque tu parlais de cet aspect de masculinité toxique.
J'sais pas, idéologiquement aussi, un truc où on se dit : mais on n'a pas envie de remettre ça en question. Enfin, c'est évident que ça doit être là.
Clairement. Moi, c'était-- il y avait clairement, à un moment donné, un socle, en tout cas de valeurs, qui aussi impulsent des comportements plutôt que d'autres et qui les valident.
Et ça, ce refus d'adresser ce problème-là, de remettre en question ce socle, de masculinisme, de virilité, est-ce qu'il est encore là un petit peu ?
Est-ce que vous y avez été confronté dans votre enquête ?
Dans l'enquête liée au scoutisme-
En parlant avec les fédérations, par exemple.
Je pense que le plus grand ennemi, c'est l'inertie, en fait.
Mh.
C'est le fait que, d'avoir-
Inertie, inertie motivée par le fait qu'on n'a pas envie de remettre la masculinité toxique en question.
Alors, je dirais pas pour la fédération principale, je pense pas que ce soit ça.
Mh.
Je crois que c'est vraiment : j'ai dix mille autres défis à faire.
OK.
Je ne prends pas la juste mesure de ce que vous me racontez. Et il y a une forme d'inertie qui fait que je vais mobiliser
deux, trois outils pédagogiques, mais plutôt à la marge, ce qui va me donner l'impression de prendre en charge le problème.
Et le fait à un moment donné qu'un journalisme vienne mettre la lumière assez crue
sur ce qu'étaient ces violences les oblige à reprendre leurs deux, trois outils pédagogiques qu'ils avaient laissés en périphérie et à leur dire : OK, maintenant, c'est au cœur
des enjeux qui sont autour du scoutisme.
Et c'est ce qui a permis à Médor et ce que permet d'autres enquêtes, d'autres médias, c'est à un moment donné de ramener au centre des violences qui sont subies, des injustices-
Mettre la lumière sur le non-dit, finalement.
Sur le non-dit, ou oui, ou sur, moi, je reviens à ça, sur une forme d'inertie.
Mh.
Tant que quelqu'un ne nous dit pas de nous préoccuper de ce sujet, on n'a aucune raison de s'en préoccuper.
Mh. Mh.
Donc ça, c'était il y a un an, comme je le disais, juin 2023. Donc ça donne, si vous ne connaissez pas Médor, ça donne une bonne idée de, voilà, le genre de sujet, le genre de travail qui vous stimule, qui vous passionne.
Et à ce propos, donc, un nouveau numéro vient de sortir, le numéro 35. Est-ce que tu peux nous en parler un petit peu ?
C'est l'instant pub.
Alors, l'instant pub, le numéro 35 va vous transporter, ben notamment en Europe, puisqu'on a un sujet qui va évoquer harcèlement, sexisme au niveau des institutions européennes, peut-être le dernier bastion-
Mh.
de la masculinité toxique. Enfin, peut-être, sans doute pas le dernier, mais en tout cas-
Dernier ? Pourquoi tu dis ça ?
Un des derniers. Non, parce qu'il y a eu quand même des-
S'il suffit de terminer celui-là-
Non, non, non, non. Y a eu-- parce qu'il y a eu quand même des révélations et des prises de conscience-
Ah oui, dernier dans l'actualité. Le plus récent, oui.
Ouais, dans différents milieux. Donc on a ce sujet, on a le portrait de la chanteuse Muriel Dake, qui avait fait Tropisme dans mon cœur, change pas de moteur.
Je sais pas si ça te dit quelque chose, mais qui a glissé vers une forme de complotisme.
D'accord.
Et c'est un portrait qui est tout en nuance, pas du tout dans une forme folklorique, striptisienne de
d'un portrait d'une complotiste, mais qui essaye plutôt de comprendre comment à un moment donné, des colères peuvent être mal placées, en fait.
Si, je vois, le McDo, le Delhaize, le...
Oui. L'installation d'un McDo à Tervuren et la révolte des Nantois qui refusent que le McDo s'installe tout près de chez eux.
Il y a un focus sur les franchisés de Delhaize un an plus tard. Donc, comme tu le disais, on est beaucoup dans des enjeux de société.
Ouais.
Et aussi, on l'espère, dans une approche éditoriale qui permet de découvrir ou redécouvrir des sujets qu'on connaissait déjà à travers des, voilà, des écrits qui sont-
Ce qui est intéressant avec ce package d'enquêtes finalement assez diverses, c'est que
on finit par s'intéresser à des sujets qu'on n'aurait pas creusés spontanément et on découvre des choses et on comprend mieux des choses qu'on n'aurait pas forcément pensé explorer spontanément.
Eh ben, c'est une chose que je défends de plus en plus dans Médor et qui n'était pas du tout un trait de caractère et qu'il est devenu-
Mh.
à cause de l'évolution de la société, c'est-à-dire que Médor n'est pas du tout algorithmique.
Ouais, c'est ça.
C'est-à-dire que
tu vas pouvoir découvrir toute une série de
sujets et qu'en effet, là, on mise sur ton envie et ta curiosité, mais tu vas avoir un article pêche et ensuite tu vas avoir un article Commission européenne et on va enchaîner avec un papier sur,
je sais pas, les franchisés.
Et donc, si tu es fan de VTT, tu vas pas retrouver des VTT, mais donc on est dans une dimension qui du coup devient une revendication de dire : on ne donne pas ce que les gens attendent.
Mh. Ou alors on les attire avec un sujet qui peut les intéresser et puis on leur fait découvrir-
Oui.
deux autres sujets.
Ouais. C'est comme ceux qui défendent la TV linéaire finalement, pour dire : bon, on va vous montrer des trucs, c'est pas pour ça que vous avez zappé sur cette chaîne, mais voilà une surprise.
Ouais, une offre aléatoire.
Ouais, ouais, c'est ça. Qu'est-ce qu'on peut te souhaiter pour la suite de Médor ? Est-ce que vous avez des projets en chantier que vous espérez avoir terminés dans les douze mois qui viennent ?
Ben ce qu'on peut nous souhaiter, outre de survivre, c'est, moi, je pense, de continuer à porter l'envie d'être un laboratoire et de s'inventer ou de se réinventer.
J'ai vraiment envie de tester des nouvelles formes de journalisme, de tester des nouvelles rencontres, et de-- voilà, moi, je reviens dans le Médor de décembre dans un an.
J'ai envie déjà d'y réfléchir avec ma partenaire du numéro et d'essayer, pas juste pour essayer, pas faire un coup, mais de pouvoir en profiter pour en faire des outils de laboratoire, ouais.
Et c'est ce que je nous souhaite pendant douze mois, c'est de continuer à faire
du journalisme à la fois d'intérêt public, parce que c'est quand même important de nourrir notre société, mais aussi du journalisme qui requestionne le journalisme. Voilà.
Journalisme média, alors. Peut-être un petit peu-
Ou méta, en tout cas.
Méta.
Ouais.
Oui, c'est ça. Mais du coup, on te souhaite, on vous souhaite d'atteindre tous ces objectifs et une très bonne continuation.
On vous souhaite de survivre aussi. Oui, ce serait pas mal. Et on vous souhaite du coup, déjà en avance, un dixième anniversaire en 2025 alors.
Voilà.
Ça s'approche. Ça s'approche.
On refait la fête.
Super. Merci beaucoup Olivier.
Merci à toi.
Et voilà, c'est déjà tout pour cette saison de Septante Minutes Avec. Enfin, pas tout à fait puisqu'il reste comme chaque année un épisode estival que je vais faire en solo normalement, avec pas mal d'annonces, vous allez voir.
Et c'est pas de l'esbroufe. Je risque de parler de santé mentale un petit peu dans cet épisode, un peu dans la continuation de, voilà, ce qu'on a pu aborder avec Fiona le mois dernier.
D'ailleurs, merci beaucoup, hein, pour vos messages enjoués. Vous êtes nombreuses et nombreux à avoir apprécié l'épisode qu'on a fait sur le trouble borderline.
Ça nous a fait fort plaisir. Et au passage, j'ai fait le montage un petit peu différemment cette fois-ci, pour l'épisode avec Olivier Bailly.
N'hésitez pas à me signaler si vous avez vu la différence. On se retrouve à la rentrée avec des nouvelles interviews. De super guests sont déjà bookés.
Plein de sujets passionnants, vous allez voir. N'hésitez pas à soutenir et à lire Médor aussi, c'est vraiment cool. Si vous ne connaissez pas encore, ça risque très fort de vous plaire.
Et quant à moi, je vous souhaite un très bel été. Portez-vous bien. À très bientôt.